♪ Why dontcha do whatcha
do whatcha do whatcha do ♪
(doo wop singing)
♪ Why do you do...
- Thanks for coming to
the OCD support group,
next up is the bipolar group.
I know we have a lot
of overlap, thank you.
- Hi, I'm Myra by the way.
- Oh hi, I'm Gina.
- Nice to meet you.
Are you staying for the
next one by any chance?
- Probably.
- I really like what you had
to say about picturing your
bubbie's breasts every time
a guy goes down on you.
I totally relate.
As you might have heard, I have
some issues with my grandpa.
- Incest OCD?
- Yeah, that's just the
one I can talk about.
- I feel you there.
And like, I'm at this dog
shelter, and for some reason,
like, the only thing I can
even picture in my head--
- Bestiality stuff?
- Yeah, exactly.
- And sometimes it's
like the ugly dogs
that smell the worst, right?
- It's always the worst dogs.
I never, I would love
to be attracted to
like, a good looking
dog, just once.
- I love that part
of your head so much,
I don't know what I
would do without you.
- Aw, thanks.
(phone chiming)
Oh, sorry.
Oh that's cool!
Um, I just got invited to this
feminist talk in New York.
They want women of
all different ages
to discuss female circumcision
for an all male audience.
I think it's gonna be
like, super cool, honey.
- When do you leave me?
- Oh, I don't know, probably
like, a week or something?
- And for how long?
- Five days?
I mean there's a lot
to see in New York.
- A lot can happen in five days.
(intense static)
- Bye, sweetie.
(door opens)
(whimpering)
(door closes)
(melancholy music)
(plate shatters)
- No, I'm not...
(crying)
(whines)
Ow!
(crying) Ow!
Why Gina?
Gina...
Gina!
(door opens)
- Oh God, you look rough, man.
- I just missed you so much.
Can you please
just make me dinner
and tell me
everything'll be okay?
(cries)
Please?
Just make me dinner.
(birds chirping)
- Alright, well it's getting
late and I have to go to work.
- No, don't leave.
- I have to.
We're talking to
preschoolers today
about sexual harassment
in the classroom.
It's an issue.
Alright, well I'll
see you later, okay?
- No.
No.
- [Gina] Can you let go please?
- [Myra] No.
(thud)
Don't leave, I
need you too much.
- Can um...
- No!
- Can I get up please?
- Please no, you can't.
You can only get up if
you promise to not leave.
- I need you to let go.
- [Myra] No I'm in love
with you, you have to stay.
- I need you to let go.
- I'm not letting go.
- Let go!
- I have an iron grip of love.
Please don't.
Gina, no.
Stop, you're hurting my arms.
No, you can't leave me.
Please don't leave me.
- If you don't let go
I'm calling the police.
- I'll call the cops and
tell them to stay away.
I don't care!
(handcuffs clinking)
- Will you come with me?
- No.
(cries)
(violin)